[Musique]
oui c'est sûr ça fait rêver d'avoir des
joueurs comme ceux qui réussissent des
Canadiens on a la chance d'avoir une
génération brillante tout simplement
pour la deuxième Coupe
du monde c'est un exploit immense
seulement 32 nations participent à la
Coupe du Monde et le Canada a fait sa
place avec panache
pays divers et de plus en plus pays de
soccer
[Musique]
les garçons de 15 ans du club de soccer
de longueuils sont champions canadien le
socker est une passion et fait partie de
leur quotidien ils s'apprêtent à vivre
de bons moments je trouve ça vraiment
cool que il qualifie vu que d'habitude
ici au Canada le hockey pose toujours
avant le secret puis si ça donne
l'expiration pour travailler plus fort
ici puis peut-être toujours arriver à ce
niveau-là aussi le monde change de
football change et je suis très fier
pour le Canada qui réussit à faire cet
exploit et qui a motivé beaucoup de
jeunes beaucoup tu passes avant centre
et donc Elias et Ewan sur les côtés le
CS Longueuil compte aujourd'hui 2700
joueurs soit 500 de plus qu'en 2015 ici
comme partout au pays les succès de
l'équipe nationale ont une influence
directe sur la traite du sport on voit
de plus en plus de jeunes joués au parc
prendre leur ballon et moi qui viens de
France et là dedans que j'ai grandi et
je pense que le soccer prend de plus en
plus de place de par les de par les
différentes cultures
[Musique]
enthousiasme aussi à Laval chez l'équipe
féminine québécoise des 17 ans Jade
bordelaud a représenté le Canada lors de
la Coupe du Monde des U17 cet automne on
est un peu les under dogs si je peux
dire mais je crois que c'est ça qui nous
rend
canadien puis fort parce que je crois
que c'est un peu ça qui est dans nos
veines de Canadiens pour propulser mais
non
[Applaudissements]
Jade et ses coéquipières ont déjà trouvé
une inspiration dans les succès de
l'équipe canadienne olympique depuis
encadré on a plus de projets pour nous
on a plus de personnes qui là pour nous
soutenir au 30 septembre on avait
162.000 joueurs et joyeuses qui jouent
qui joue soccer sur territoire québécois
plus de 50 000 filles pas loin du double
de pratique
l'intérêt porté au socker professionnel
est encore bien loin de celui porté au
hockey bien loin aussi de la passion
sud-américaine ou européenne pour le
foot mais les succès internationaux du
Canada commencent à rapporter
dans le monde sportif bien entendu on
attend cet événement de façon
extraordinaire asun camarade lui aussi
ancien joueur de Marseille puis de
l'impact il a suivi de près l'éclosion
de plusieurs stars locales comme iPhone
souris ou Samuel Piette j'ai envie que
leur leur exploits s'améliorer soit mis
en avant que les médias on parle
beaucoup plus les médias plus
généraliste parce qu'il y a des belles
histoires sportives à aller chercher
mais aussi des histoires humaines
derrière ces joueurs qui trouve que le
Canada est vraiment respecté au niveau
soccer aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
de nouveau tout nouveau on n'avait pas
l'habitude d'être considéré comme un
comme une terre de foot de soccer comme
pour appuyer ces propos cette immense
bannière boulevard Saint-Laurent à
Montréal le magasin spécialisé en soccer
qui l'a installé vend une quarantaine de
chandails du Canada chaque jour
comme ça pour le Canada pas client qui
rentre pratiquement on parle Canada
qu'est-ce que tu penses ils vont faire
est-ce que ils sont capables à battre de
Belgique ou le Croatie j'en ai officiel
que l'équipe va porter chante à gazarian
a acheté deux chandails et c'est au
Qatar qu'il valait porter passionné de
socquerre il part réaliser son rêve en
famille
et avoir le Canada qui fait partie ça a
vraiment été quelque chose qui nous a
plus ou moins obligé d'aller
faire un grand voyage il vient de
recevoir ses billets qu'il nous montre
fièrement Canada contre Belgique et
Canada contre Croatie on fait ça tout ça
pour le pour le Canada pour après tous
ensemble pour vraiment célébrer une
grande occasion
pour de nombreux Canadiens la simple
présence du Canada à la Coupe du Monde
et déjà une grande victoire un rappel
aussi que c'est ici dans quatre ans
qu'aura lieu la prochaine le soccer
canadien vit une belle époque
[Musique]